Are you behind the fake Chariot?
Are you mocking me?
Why are you here?
There's something I want to ask.
You can answer all questions about
the past, present and future, can't you?
Not all.
But what I cannot answer, nobody can.
I want you to tell me about my future.
Can I really become a witch like Chariot?
Foolishness.
This is more important to me than my life!
Is this the future you wish?
That's my... dream.
Step through the door.
The future will be yours.
But when you get the bright future,
you will lose your past.
What do you mean?
The future comes with a price.
You must sacrifice your past.
Your useless past...
will be erased.
Wait!
Don't erase them!
My past is full of failures
and almost nothing went right,
but I don't want to erase those memories!
Why?
They are not worth saving.
The tears, the frustrations, the laughs...
they're all mine. No one else's.
They're everything I have done.
I did my best!
I'm not going to erase them!
Are you all right...
with not becoming Chariot?
I can be!
I will be an amazing witch
through my own hard work.
The professor taught me...
"You don't get that which you dream of,
but what you work hard for."
Phaidoari...
Afairrynghor!